[Music]
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business i don't these are
dangerous people team two is clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me
this is a really good plan too i can go
back inside and you can still do it
that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail a mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell must listen
up you're the leader you're supposed to
be decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
like angels are splooting all over us
i think it's going to surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
it's going to be different from any
superhero movie ever made
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
than james gunn i was excited with an
opportunity to be able to do
the suicide squad in the way it could be
done from my point of view
this one is completely unique this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters and comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad is just
a twisted fantasy of characters
within each of our characters there's a
certain beauty
with the most of them some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
be like a douchey captain america the
guy who
believes in peace at any cost no matter
how many people he needs to
kill along the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because you
don't
as soon as you have some sense about
what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone's exploding genitals heads arms
legs
it's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life
this is by far the biggest movie i've
ever made
i don't think that you know what to
expect
don't get too attached this has been
truly
the greatest most exciting
journey of my life making this film
cut that was great
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
welcome to ask force x these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
[Music]
[Music]
i'm back to the back again
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you